(clapping hands)
- [Interviewer] Flat Top,
tell me where you grew up.
- Um, I was born in
Starkville, Mississippi.
I grew up a young country man.
(mumbles)
At two, three years old,
I hunted, I fished, I did climbing
climbing the trees and riding the horses,
the whole nine yards.
I'm talking about from, from,
running through berry bushes to
picking out of the garden.
You know, I didn't chop the
lot of rows since I was young, man,
and I'd been through a whole lot
in the years that I grew up, man.
Especially coming from the country,
from the country to the city?
- [Interviewer] When'd you come out to LA?
- I came out to LA in '79.
- '79.
- [Interviewer] So you were how old then?
- I was nineteen years old.
- [Interviewer] Nineteen.
And you got involved with gangs
at what point?
- At nineteen years old.
- [Interviewer] Right then?
- Right then. South Central. Yes indeed.
- [Interviewer] Which gang?
- I'm from Harlam Crip.
Yes, sir, (mumbles).
Stayed over that for 39 years.
My first,
my attempted murder,
was at 19 years old.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so you...
- I was just six months.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- Six months and they gave me a gun to
go try to gun somebody down.
And I think I was as
scared as the guy was.
At 19 years old, sir,
you're not thinking about going
to kill nobody.
But, during that time,
either you did them or they did you.
Your home is your home gang,
you know what I'm saying?
It was like, it was like turning
your back on them.
But, you know,
I did what I did
and, at 19 and 20 years old
I did another attempt.
But you know, the fighting,
and the stabbing and the cutting,
all these scars that I've got on my body,
before I was 21 years
old I got shot twice.
- [Interviewer] So you didn't get
thrown in jail? Or prison?
- No, I didn't close.
Never got caught.
- [Interviewer] Never got caught?
- Never got caught.
- [Interviewer] Now let me
back up a bit.
Was it this change of environment
that kind of got you into
this violent lifestyle,
or did you have some childhood...
- No, it was change of environment.
- [Interviewer] It was
change of environment.
Did you grow up with both
parents or one parent?
- Both parents.
- [Interviewer] Both parents.
Normal childhood...
- Normal childhood.
- [Interviewer] Country boy growing up
in Mississippi...
- Country boy going to
church every Sunday.
- [Interviewer] And then you
come out to this...
- Come out to here and...
- [Interviewer] Get yourself involved in
violence and peer pressure to be violent.
- To be violent.
And it turned me into that person.
That I didn't really want to be,
but because I had joined this gang,
that's what it was, so...
- [Interviewer] And in that neighborhood,
there's no other option other than
join a gang?
- No other option.
- [Interviewer] You couldn't become
an A student and become...
- That wasn't gonna happen.
I think out of my hood,
in the 30 years I'd been there,
I maybe know two head students
that actually went to college.
You know what I'm saying?
Because, everything else was street life.
You know, you was raised in the streets.
And I was raised in the streets.
- [Interviewer] So back to your,
your 21 years old?
- 21 years old.
Man, I went on a drive by.
And, it was women and kids.
To where they're pointing,
my homeboys didn't care.
But I did.
Because I could not kill no
women or no kids.
Because them young people
had did none to me.
You know what I'm saying?
And I got disciplined for that.
- [Interviewer] For kind of standing up?
- For not shooting up,
- [Interviewer] For not shooting them?
- I got really disciplined.
To the point where I was in the
hospital for five days.
Yes, they are, they are treacherous.
When it comes to,
to upholding your place in a gang.
Especially if you're in one of
the ones I come from.
You know, and 22, 23 years old,
I was in Pelican Bay.
Pelican Bay for assault
with a deadly weapon.
It was an iron pipe to one of
my enemies heads from,
from, from twenties.
But, the thing about it,
he didn't die.
But, you know, he came close.
And, being that I was so young,
my first time in prison,
it scared me to death.
Because Pelican Bay was the
worst prison in California.
And at the age of 24 years old,
man, it was like you was being
reborn all again.
Because you was told when to eat,
when to shit, when to move,
when to sleep.
And, I wasn't used to that.
So, about nine months into Pelican Bay,
I caught another shoot term.
Thirteen more shoots.
They sent me from Pelican Bay to Corcoran.
Corcoran, therefore you only come out
of your cell for one hour a day.
So I did these thirteen months
for one day out of a week
and you picked the day.
Your showers came to your cell,
your food came to your cell,
your mail came to your cell,
everything came to your cell.
And when we used to go outside
it was a lot of tension between
the blacks and the essays.
Why?
Because of the COs.
They used to bet on that.
- [Interviewer] What?
- The COs, the correction officers,
used to bet who would win these
fights between the
blacks and the Mexicans.
Until one person got killed
and they found out about it and
it blew up in their face.
Because they would, say me for instance,
they would put me in a cage
and five minutes later
here come five essays.
Into the same cage.
Now what's the first, my first, reaction?
Let's get closer to the door and
hit the first one come in,
cause there was no other alternative.
- [Interviewer] Essays are...
- Hispanics.
Yeah, gang members, and
back then you had some gang members that,
Hispanics that would kill a black
before they would eat a piece of bread.
Believe me, and, so,
when I got out of Corcoran,
out of Corcoran's (mumbles),
I came home.
Back downtown, homeless.
At the age of 24 years old.
Out here on these streets,
people manipulate you.
They, they try to take over your mind.
They try to take over
anything that you got.
But me being raised the way I was raised,
I'm a very strong person
to the point of where I see through
a whole lot of the bull crap that
they was bringing.
And two years down here, sir,
I got shot right here.
I was dancing, I was
dancing on the sidewalk,
me and three girls.
And the same dude that
I hit with this pipe,
is the one that shot me.
He tried to shoot me in my back.
I know that's what he
was really trying to do
to paralyze me.
'Cause, uh, I heard through the
grapevine that he didn't want me to die,
he just wanted me to be paralyzed.
So I could roll around in that shell
the rest of my life.
But because of one of the
ladies standing behind me
told me he had a gun, I turned.
And therefore it hit me here,
instead of in the spine.
'Cause it was a .45,
it would have really, really torn me up.
(siren wail)
After that, after that gun shot, man,
I got into smoking crack cocaine.
Very, very, very, very heavy.
I'm talking about at least a half ounce
to an ounce a day.
- [Interviewer] How much is that?
- That's maybe, three to four hundred
dollars a day.
And, I'm to like this...
I would be up for seven, eight,
nine, ten days at a time.
Drinking and smoking and running around.
I would go a hundred miles in a
five block radius.
Five block radius and I would go
through them five blocks
in them days, man,
a hundred miles in a day.
Just back and forth.
On that crack BS.
Crack led me to going to prison again.
I went back to prison for a burglary.
A residential burglary.
And this was in 1992.
I ended up back in Corcoran.
Beyond.
Six months into Corcoran,
we had a riot.
Blacks against the Mexicans.
It was, it was 29 people
that had to be air lifted
from Corcoran shoot to the hospital.
Because, there was a lot of stabbing.
You know, when you in prison back then
in them times, man,
it wasn't all fighting
and you know that's it,
it was a lot of people getting stabbed.
And, thank god I wasn't one of them.
But you know,
I get out again.
I get out of prison.
Back downtown.
Ohhh, I'm gonna go into a program,
I'm gonna do that right thing.
Go to a program, say maybe,
estimate eight days.
I'm back on the street.
Back with the same routine.
Same people.
That's why I say,
if you do the same thing over and over,
you're gonna get the same results.
So, I'd been trying, every now and then,
try and live a little bit different.
But, like I tell people,
if I'm not ready, can't
nobody make me ready
to stop using drugs.
I've been using drugs
since I was 13 years old.
- [Interviewer] Do you
still use them today?
- I still use drugs to this day
and I'm 59 years old.
And I know I don't look it,
because penitentiary
preserves you, believe me.
I really did 25 years
of my life in prison.
And I've been to 13 penitentiaries.
And that's bad to say.
But, it is what it is
when you're a gang banger.
Gang banging led me to a life of misery.
And, '96...
'96, I was terrible.
I didn't care about nothing.
Or nobody.
I was smoking crack and shine, together.
Which was a deadly mixer.
I mean deadly.
To where, the crack
put me in a happy mood.
The shine put me in a bad mood.
And, I had the shine
take over the good mood,
now I'm in a bad mood.
Now I want to fight everybody,
I want to kill everybody,
and it led to prison.
After prison term after prison term.
Because, your life out on the streets
is survival.
I mean real survival.
Because you could be
somewhere asleep, sir,
and someone could come up and (mumbles).
It's always one person I hear watching,
everybody believe me,
somebody's watching it.
If you're doing drugs,
if you get these nice bikes,
if you've got these nice clothes,
you working for this drug dealer,
people gonna watch you.
And they have to get what you getting.
One way or another,
get you out of the way,
or get it from you.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, which they have tried.
Sir, I've been so paranoid
that I got to where
I knew I could hear someone talking
about me four blocks away.
And that's impossible.
But the drugs had me that strung up.
To where, I thought I heard people
talking about me.
90s, '98, '99...
I came back, I went to prison again
for, I think it was,
failure to report.
They gave me two years.
So, at the '98, sir,
my time was going until like
probation violation.
Six to ten months, two years, three years.
I'm right back out in
12 months, 13 months.
And it was the same thing.
To the point where,
I really wanted to go back home
but then again,
I had met so many people down here
that this was my family.
I considered them my family
in Los Angeles, California.
And my people used to tell me
all the time, I used to call them,
when are you coming
home to see your people?
Oh, I'm coming next month.
Next month would be December.
From January, I'm telling them I'm
coming home in January.
December, they called me and I'm
still in California.
Simply because I got stuck into this life.
And, it's like, something
in here is telling
me that, hey, you have
nothing to worry about.
No bills, you ain't got to worry about
paying no mortgage, no lights, no gas,
no nothing that you've got on the street.
So who can charge you anything?
So that's been my lifestyle.
2000s, I almost went to jail for
the rest of my life.
I caught a murder.
(mumbles) for murder, for manslaughter.
I did from 2000 to 2010.
My first prison was CRC, Narco.
CRC Narco I called two years,
first six month I was there.
Because a dude thought I was somebody else
and he just really wanted to kill me.
Really wanted to mess me up because
he said I had killed
somebody in his family.
Didn't know this dude from Adam.
But he constantly picked on me.
So, one day we got in it,
into the bathroom and I stabbed him
with a sheet of tile,
a sheet of broken tile in the neck.
And his jugular.
And I almost caused an in-house murder.
In-house murder carries
30 years off the top.
No ifs, ands, and buts.
But because the man
stayed living, I guess,
70 days and he died,
it went from murder to manslaughter.
Involuntary manslaughter.
I got out of prison in 2010.
From 2000 to 2010.
2010 I got out, came back to the streets.
No home, no family, no kids,
I didn't have none to worry about.
The little 200 dollars
they gave me was gone
before the next morning.
Next morning I couldn't buy a
cup of a coffee and a donut.
But you know what,
I was still out here on the streets.
I was still doing what I was doing.
I kept robbing, stealing,
whatever I had to do to survive.
Until something stopped me.
2011 I stopped gang banging.
Because I was tired.
I was getting old.
I had got shot too many times.
Bullets hurt real bad.
Believe me, they hurt.
And because I stopped gang banging
I got into, I got into 30 fights.
30 of my homeboys had to jump me out.
Did you know,
lining up for 30 people,
30 young dudes to fight in one day?
In one day, I lost both of my front teeth,
I had black eyes over black eyes,
but because I stood my ground and
I fought everybody,
they let me out.
2012 I got out of the Harlem Crip,
I stopped banging.
I still represent the hood,
but I don't bang.
Some of my little homeboys are down here.
Right now today.
And they see me and they acknowledge,
they accept that I'm no
longer a gang banger,
but I'm a gang member.
- [Interviewer] You took
all that to get out?
- To get out.
It took all of that, sir,
to get out of gang banging.
It's easy to get in, but
it's hell to get out.
You have to almost lose your life
to get out of gang banging.
2013 I caught another assault
with a deadly weapon.
Right down here on Sixth and San Julian.
Dude tried to rob me
and I hit him with a bat.
I hit him in (mumbles) with a bat.
And that was one of the
worst days of my life,
hitting that man with that bat.
Because, you know, I,
brain matter and the whole thing, sir,
I cracked his skull.
Wide open, downtown, sir.
In the middle of Sixth and San Julian.
Didn't care.
Didn't care at all.
But my little homeboys scooped me up,
drove me away.
I got lucky because nobody tell on me.
Because I had that much clout
to where I was selling that much dope
and I was giving that much dope away
to the people that was
around me that smoked.
I had a guy that fronted me,
he fronted me like three
ounces of dope a day.
And all he wanted was 300 dollars.
I make 300 dollars off
a half ounce of dope.
So therefore, people was giving me like
a bushel or bricks compared to one prune.
And I took that and I ran with it, sir,
and I, I was getting high on top of high.
Around 2010, I mean 2015,
I kind of really, really
calmed down and wondered,
realized that I was moving too fast.
And I did, I met a young lady,
we kicked it, we kicked it.
And she got pregnant.
She got pregnant, I went to jail.
But not me knowing that she was pregnant
in 2006, I went to jail.
2000...
Love was born in October
the seventh, 2006.
Uh, I say around April around 2007
I got out of prison.
Um, it was just for a violation.
I was in a program, I
was in the wine going.
I had been in the wine
going maybe five months.
And my case manager came up and
said I had a visit.
I said I had a visit?
All my people is in Mississippi,
so how can I have a visit from somebody?
So I go downstairs, and there's this girl,
that I had sex with one time...
and ended up being 12.
She was 12 years old from one time
having sex with this lady.
I have a 12 year old daughter named Love.
Right today, sir, my daughter,
she comes down here and she knows
I don't hold nothing back from her.
You know what I'm saying?
Nothing at all.
And she told me, on your own
dad when you ready, you're gonna stop.
And I said either I'm gonna stop
and keep on living or I'm gonna die,
but I'm not scared to do either one.
You know what I'm saying?
My baby is...I don't know if she's
got the old soul or not,
but she has taught me a lot from
the age of 8 to 12 about this life.
About just life in general.
My baby mama can't stand me.
But I don't know why.
She used to take my daughter places
that she knew I couldn't come out
because I was on parole.
Couldn't leave 50 mile radius.
You leave the 50 mile radius,
you going back to prison
if anybody catch you.
So therefore, man, I've
just been in and out,
in and out, in and out.
And today I'm,
I'm happy to say that
I'm not on probation or parole.
As of 2019.
And, I'm going through to get my housing.
I'm going through to get my dental.
I'm going through to get
everything, it's real.
My eyes have opened.
I still get high, everyday.
But, when my appointments come,
I've got them logged down, believe me.
And I haven't missed an appointment since
I've been out this last six months.
So, therefore,
that was my life,
out here on these streets.
It wasn't good, it wasn't bad.
But it was all right.
I'm still here.
- [Interviewer] Still standing.
- Still standing, sir.
- [Interviewer] Flat Top, thank you
so much for sharing your story.
- Not a problem, not a problem.